this afternoon an American astronaut
will get his second shot at going into
orbit after a harrowing first attempt
last October Nick Hague was on his way
to the International Space Station on a
Russian Soyuz rocket a catastrophic
booster malfunction forcing the crew to
abort mid-flight yikes Hague and his
crew mate a Russian cosmonaut landed
safely in December NASA announced that
Hague would fly again and today is that
day
marc kossmann spoke to him and his wife
mark good morning to you good morning
turns out it was a faulty sensor that
cost Nick Hague as original mission and
also temporarily grounded the Soyuz
program when he rides on another Soyuz
today he'll fly with his old crew mate
cosmonaut Alexei of chena an American
astronaut Christina cook they'll blast
off from Kazakhstan for a seven-month
stay aboard the space station astronaut
Nick Hague has learned all about the
element of chance his first Soyuz flight
his first trip to space ran out of luck
and quickly two minutes after launch
climbing at 4,000 miles per hour one of
the separating boosters slammed into the
side of the main rocket and burst into a
cloud of debris and then all of a sudden
there was this violent shaking
side-to-side
and the alarms going off and I see a red
light that's lit up and it says that
you've had an emergency with the booster
the abort system flung the crew capsule
up and away
landing them safely Hague had this
emotional reunion with his wife Katie
you were supposed to go out for six
months you were back on earth in 20
minutes yeah you land on the ground and
you walk away safe and you know that
okay I'm around and I can give this
another shot
did it flash through your mind that
might have been my only shot oh
absolutely it's a high at this point
right at that edge of space you know 50
miles a crew member aboard the space
station snapped this bittersweet photo
look closely you can see the Soyuz
capsule just before gravity pulled it
back down to earth what goes through
your mind when you look at
at photo life doesn't always work out
the way you plan it and and more often
than not what defines you is how you
bounce back from that and this is that
moment on Tuesday a new Soyuz rocket
rolled out to the Russian launch pad hey
doesn't think he's pushing his luck by
flying in a machine that has already
failed him once after all he's living
proof its abort system works any
trepidation about going back up I don't
think so not not more than it was the
first time what we're doing up there on
the space station every day it's
important you know we're trying to open
humanity's eyes discover new things make
life better on the ground and push
further into the universe and so you
accept the risk because you believe in
what you're doing so the other member of
Team egg which is do you have any
hesitation about it not as a patient
about about him going again nervous I'm
nervous oh yes yes that's different
every little piece has to work perfectly
and and it's scary to be the spouse and
to watch it from the outside it's very
scary but I I agree with with what Nick
said I mean this is this is an important
mission and I go back to that to help
calm my nerves will I be terrified while
I'm watching it yes we'll be terrified
astronauts will always tell you that
launches are harder on the spouses than
on the crew assuming all goes well on
the ground this time around Hague will
be busy up there next week he's
scheduled to go on a spacewalk Wow as
much as I like mark I really like Katie
what a great man I love the the look
between them remember that I remember
that hug that hug was so known forever
and she actually emailed me this morning
said excited but nervous and just keep
telling yourself we got this yeah you
know he talked happened twice he talked
about space travel opening humanity's
eyes and it surely does through the
exploration but but the failure and His
grace and their Grace in handling the
failure that opens your eyes to and that
shot that took from the space
everybody in America is on Team hey vark
thank you thank you